Ngân hàng nhé nước cho biết trong tháng buổi sẽ chính chính phủ dự thảo nghĩ que thí điểm
về sản dấu dịch vang tại Việt Nam nhằm khơi thông của lực vang trong dân và mấyng
bệnh khoá hợp mùa bản vang.
Vyêu thịnh lập sản dấu dịch vang được xem là bước đi đồng bộ sâu khi chính phủ
bán hành giĩ đện 2018 xử đổi giĩ đện 2020 về con lý kinh dân vang và thung
từ 2018 xến thực hiện. Mục tiêu là hình thành kênh sâu dịch chính thức, kìm sốt
được vườn vang nhập khẩu, hạn chia sâu dịch tự rong ngoài thị trường.
Sản dấu dịch vang sẽ được trường hay theo ba dài đoạn bất đồng với sâu dịch vang
với liệu nghiệp khẩu. Sao đó, một dụng săng vang miếng và tín tối sản tập chung hiện đại dấu dịch vang trong nước,
chúng chỉ vang và công cụ phay sinh, bởi đảm miếng bệnh an toàn và hiệu quà.